what's up with jesse smilette
and by that the only thing i'm talking
about is
why is his name not jesse
it's a handsome ass [ __ ] but he
shaves his mustache and leaves his beard
like he's [ __ ] abe lincoln no
hey man are you the 16th president no
grow your stash out or shave the beard
too hey
jesse what the [ __ ] are you doing
why'd you [ __ ] hire two guys
from mad cobra to come beat you up
those guys are the most muscly guys of
all time dude they rehearsed it
oh it's not a [ __ ] musical
just go out there and beat them up
pretend
dude such a wacko [ __ ] thing to do
jesse um cross
hey what's your name my name is crust
dalia
beat me up here's 500 guys from mad
cobra
dude those guys look so much like they
[ __ ] are
huge huge reggae stars
the people the two guys who beat up
jesse smallett
look so much like [ __ ] huge
reggae stars flicks
got paid 3 500 dollars to beat up jesse
flex
made us rehearse it one time and do for
real flex
time josie smiley let us beat him
up we took the money ah then we got
carter then we told the [ __ ] cops we
don't care
we in over our heads uh we snitch
immediately we look the same
flex we're so muscular
why did they pick us we're so
identifiable flicks
they said we had maga hats on but we're
two black guys why would we do that
flex huh why would we call him the
n-word if we are both black
a flex this does not make sense
i mean dude the whole thing makes
no sense the picture of them at runyon
canyon that they use from tmz
with puka shells on in an open hoodie
holding
[ __ ] each other like they're
literally took the picture of
what are you talking about huh yeah yeah
did you guys beat up
jesse smullet what are you talking about
yeah it's illegal
yeah oh no he paid us flex
time the other six can we finish the
hike right now
i can't believe this whole [ __ ] mess
look at the guys he
pick white guys you [ __ ] idiot
pick asians pick [ __ ] armadillos
you picked black guys
you picked black guys and you said that
they were yelling out
trump nation no
they weren't
dude i want to step backwards for all
the victims
[ __ ] this is why you can't believe
everybody this guy's never gonna work
again it doesn't even matter
cardi b said he feel like he [ __ ] i
feel like he [ __ ] up black history
month bro
goddamn yeah no [ __ ] dude i mean the
guys he picked is so funny the guys he
picked the guys don't
have a care in the world yeah we do it
for three three thousand five hundred
dollars yeah
and the cops were like did you do it
they were like yeah uh they're i mean
they're probably don't they're probably
not jamaican they look [ __ ] jamaican
though they look like
this is funnier for some reason
weren't they extras in this show too
like what are you doing
dude outsource it here's ola osundario
man tied to justice millet case on
empire
wow dude just wow